what you actually need to do is send
mixed signals because think about it
whenever someone has sent you mixed
signals that's when you've started to
psychoanalyze and figure out what went
wrong and that is when you get hooked so
how do you send mixed signals easy
you're going to create Pleasure and Pain
let's start with pleasure give this
person attention give them hope let them
get comfortable almost like they're in
an ocean with unlimited supplies of
water next up pain you're gonna take
them from that ocean and drop them in
the desert okay no more water supply in
other words no contact because that's
when they're gonna get confused and
that's when they're gonna worry that
they lost you the less certain they are
the more obsessed they'll become oh my
God I'm so glad I'm not single I am so
glad thank you God thank you Jesus by
the way um if you're in an ocean you do
not have an unlimited supply of water
oceans are uh are salt water and you
can't drink that'll actually kill you
faster a lot faster than drinking
nothing at all don't you know the poem
water water everywhere so let's all have
a drink